what is the largest star in the universe
and why is it that large and what are
stars anyway
things that would like to be stars
we begin our journey with earth not to
learn anything just to get a vague sense
of scale
the smallest things that have some
star-like properties are large gas
giants or sub-brown dwarfs like jupiter
the most massive planet in the solar
system 11 times larger and 317 times
more massive than earth and more or less
made of the same stuff as our sun
just much much less of it
the transition towards stars begins with
brown dwarfs failed stars that are a
huge disappointment to their moms
they have between 13 and 90 times the
mass of jupiter so even if we took 90
jupiters and threw them at each other
although fun to watch it wouldn't be
enough to create a star interestingly
adding lots of mass to a brown dwarf
doesn't make it much bigger just its
insides denser
this increases the pressure in the core
enough to make certain nuclear fusion
reactions happen slowly and the object
glow a little
so brown dwarfs are a sort of glowy gas
giant that don't fit into any category
very well
but we want to talk about stars not
failed wannabe stars so let's move on
main sequence stars
once large gas balls pass a certain mass
threshold their cores become hot and
dense enough to ignite
hydrogen is fused to helium in their
cores releasing tremendous amounts of
energy
stars that do that are called main
sequence stars
the more massive a main sequence star is
the hotter and brighter it burns and the
shorter its life is
once the hydrogen burning phase is over
stars grow
up to hundreds of thousands of times
their original size
but these giant phases only last for a
fraction of their lifespan
so we'll be comparing stars at
drastically different stages in their
lives this doesn't make them less
impressive but maybe it's good to keep
in mind that we'll be comparing babies
to adults
now back to the beginning
the smallest real stars are red dwarfs
about 100 times the mass of jupiter
barely massive enough to fuse hydrogen
to helium because they are not very
massive they are small not very hot and
shine pretty dimly
they are the only stars in the main
sequence that don't grow once they die
but sort of fizzle out
red dwarfs are by far the most abundant
type in the universe because they burn
their fuel very slowly it lasts them up
to 10 trillion years a thousand times
the current age of the universe
for example one of the closest stars to
earth is a red dwarf star barnard star
but it shines too dimly to be seen
without a telescope we made a whole
video on red dwarfs if you want to learn
more
the next stage are stars like our sun to
say the sun dominates the solar system
is not doing it justice since it makes
up
99.86 percent of all its mass
it burns far hotter and brighter than
red dwarfs which reduces its lifetime to
about 10 billion years
the sun is seven times more massive than
barnard star but that makes it nearly
300 times brighter with twice its
surface temperature
let's go bigger
small changes in mass produce enormous
changes in a main sequence star's
brightness
the brightest star in the night sky
sirius is two solar masses with a radius
1.7 times that of the sun but its
surface is nearly 10 000 degrees celsius
making it shine 25 times brighter
burning that hot reduces its total
lifespan by four times to 2.5 billion
years
stars close to 10 times the mass of our
sun have surface temperatures near 25
000 degrees celsius
beta centauri contains two of these
massive stars each shining with about 20
000 times the power of the sun that's a
lot of power coming from something only
13 times larger but they'll only burn
for about 20 million years
entire generations of these blue stars
die in the time it takes the sun to
orbit the galaxy once
so is this the formula the more massive
the larger the star
the most massive star that we know is
r136a1
it has 315 solar masses and is nearly 9
million times brighter than the sun
and yet despite its tremendous mass and
power it's barely 30 times the size of
the sun
the star is so extreme and barely held
together by gravity that it loses 321
000 billion tons of material through its
stellar wind
every single second
stars of this sort are extremely rare
because they break the rules of star
formation a tiny bit
when supermassive stars are born they
burn extremely hot and bright and this
blows away any extra gas that could make
them more massive
so the mass limit for such a star is
around 150 times the sun
stars like r136a1 are probably formed
through the merger of several high mass
stars in dense star forming regions and
burn their core hydrogen in only a few
million years
so this means they are rare and
short-lived
from here the trick to going bigger
isn't adding more mass
to make the biggest stars we have to
kill them
red giants
when main sequence stars begin to
exhaust the hydrogen in their core it
contracts making it hotter and denser
this leads to hotter and faster fusion
which pushes back against gravity and
makes the outer layers swell in a giant
phase
and these stars become truly giant
indeed
for example gacracks
only thirty percent more massive than
the sun it has swollen to about 84 times
its radius
still when the sun enters the last stage
of its life it will swell and become
even bigger
200 times its current radius
in this final phase of its life it will
swallow the inner planet
and if you think that's impressive let's
finally introduce the largest stars in
the universe
hypergiants
hypergiants are the giant phase of the
most massive stars in the universe
they have an enormous surface area that
can radiate an insane amount of light
being so large they're basically blowing
themselves apart as gravity at the
surface is too weak to hold on to the
hot mass which is lifted away in
powerful stellar winds
pistol star is 25 solar masses but 300
times the radius of the sun a blue
hypergiant aptly named for its energetic
blue starlight
it's hard to say exactly how long pistol
star will live but probably just a few
million years
even larger than the blue hypergiants
are the yellow hyper giants
the most well studied is rho cassiopeia
a star so bright it can be seen with the
naked eye although it's thousands of
light years from earth
at 40 solar masses this star is around
500 times the radius of the sun and
thousand times brighter if the earth
were as close to row cassiopeia as it is
to the sun it would be inside it and you
would be very dead
yellow hypergiants are very rare though
only 15 are known
this means they're likely just a
short-lived intermediate state as a star
grows or shrinks between other phases of
hypergiantness
with red hypergiants we reach the
largest stars known to us probably the
largest stars even possible
so who's the winner of this insane
contest
well the truth is we don't know
red hyper giants are extremely bright
and far away which means that even tiny
uncertainties in our measurements can
give us a huge margin of error for their
size
worse still red hypergiants are solar
system-sized behemoths that are blowing
themselves apart which makes them harder
to measure
as we do more science and our
instruments improve whatever the largest
star is will change
the star that is currently thought to be
among the largest we've found is
stevenson 218 it was probably born as a
main sequence star a few tens of times
the mass of the sun and has likely lost
about half its mass by now
while typical red hyper giants are 1500
times the size of the sun the largest
rough estimate places stevenson 218 at
2150 solar radii and shining with almost
half a million times the power of the
sun
by comparison the sun seems like a grain
of dust
our brains don't really have a way of
grasping this kind of scale
even at light speed it would take you
8.7 hours to travel around it once
the fastest plane on earth would take
around 500 years
dropped on the sun it would fill
saturn's orbit
as it evolves it will probably shed even
more mass and shrink down into another
hotter hypergiant phase accumulate heavy
elements in its core before finally
exploding in a core collapse supernova
giving its gas back to the galaxy
this gas will then go on to form another
generation of stars of all sizes
starting the cycle of birth and death
again to light up our universe
let's make this journey again but this
time without the talking
the universe is big
there are many large things in it
[Music]
if you want to play a bit more with size
stuff we have good news
we've created our first app universe in
a nutshell together with tim urban the
brain behind weight but y
you can seamlessly travel from the
smallest things in existence past the
coronavirus human cells and dinosaurs
all the way to the largest stars and
galaxies and marvel at the whole
observable universe
you can learn more about each object or
simply enjoy the sheer scale of it all
the app is inspired by the scale of the
universe website by the who wang twins
that we spent a lot of time with when it
came out years ago and felt that it was
finally time to create a weight book y
and kutzgazak version you can get it in
your app store there are no in-app
purchases and no ads all future updates
are included and since this is our first
app we'd love to hear your feedback so
we can improve it over time
if this sounds good to you download the
universe in a nutshell app now and leave
us a five star review if you want to
support it
kotskazak and all the projects we do are
mostly funded by viewers like you
so if you like the app we'll make more
digital things in future thank you for
watching
[Music]
you